يستمر نظام حميه البحر المتوسط الغذائي في
سيطرته على قائمه الافضل بين الانظمه
الغذائيه العالميه للسنه الخامسه على
التوالي في اطار السباق السنوي لافضها
التصنيف الجديد اكد التفوق النظام المتوسط
على انظمه عده اخرى ومنها حميه داش التي
احتلت المركز الثاني الحميه الغذائيه
المرنه في المركز الثالث
وتقلل الانظمه الغذائيه الثلاثه هذه من
استخدام الاطعمه المصنعه او تلغيها نهائيا
وتحرص على ان يتكون الطعام العناصر
النباتيه متنوعه حيث حازت الحميه
المتوسطيه على افضل التصنيفات ضمن الفئات
الاخرى كونها اسهل الانظمه الغذائيه
المتبعه وافضل الانظمه الغذائيه للوجبات
الصحيه وايضا افضل الانظمه الغذائيه لمرضى
السكري والانظمه الغذائيه النباتيه
[موسيقى]
يدل اسم حميه البحر المتوسط الغذائيه على
كونها نظام غذائي مستمد من الاطعمه التي
يتناولها ابناء البلدان التي تشاطئ البحر
الابيض المتوسط الحميه المتوسطيه تختلف
بين الدول المتوسط لكنها بشكل عام تعتمد
على نظام غذائي غني بالخضروات والفواكه
والاسماك وتشمل ايضا البقوليات والمكسرات
والدهون غير المشبعه مثل زيت الزيتون
وكميه منخفضه من اللحوم ومنتجات الالبان
الدراسات الطبيه اظهرت ان هذه الحميه حميه
البحر المتوسط تقلل من خطر الاصابات
بامراض القلب نظرا لكونها تعتمد بشكل كامل
على نظام منخفض الكوليسترول الضار
الدراسات ربطت بشكل قوي بين الحميه
المتوسطيه وانخفاض معدل الوفيات وذلك بسبب
امراض القلب والاوعيه الدمويه كذلك فان
هذه الحميه تساعد على الوقايه من سرطان
الثدي بنسبه للسيدات
[موسيقى]
في دبي تنضم الينا الشيف لما جمال مؤسسه
مطبخ ومدرسه الطهي مامالو لاما اهلا بيكي
منورتنا الشافي يسعد صباحك
قبل العام الخامس على التوالي الحميه حميه
البحر المتوسط هي الاولى عالميا انت كشاف
هذه الدراسه
كيف يعني ماده الرينين نفود بتعثر قصدك
يعني كثير هي هل في هذا النوع الاكل وهي
كثير قريبه على اكلنا نحنا العربيه هذا
النوع الاكل وفي كثير همم
بالاكل العربيه
يعني فينا نعملها مع تويست معينه مثل
اليوم نحن راح نعمل راح نستخدم
اوكي
اكل صحي من خلال مستخدمات يتم استخدامه من
خلال الوصفات
بصحي
لا اكيد اكيد صح لانه اذا بتتكون على هول
فود يعني ما في شيء بروستات خضره خضره
اللحمه لحمه بس انه طبعا اكيد من وين
بتجيبوا اللحمه من وين بتجيبوا الدجاج
يكونوا اللحمه تبعتكم جلاسفات بس اهم شيء
انه ما بنستخدم نحن الاكل البروسيست عرفت
كيف هيدا همم بهذه الفكره بتكون اكيد هذا
الاكل صحي اكتر برايه طيب لما مثلا لما
يكون في عنا نوع اكل احنا بنركز على الاكل
اللي بيحتوي على اكثر كربوهيدرات ولا اكثر
دهون
او دهون مفيده مثلا صراحه ثانيه يعني
[موسيقى]
بس برايي اكيد كل شيء هاي بروتين يعني اذا
نحن بنعرف من وين البروتين طبعا لانه في
كثير هلا لا اللحمه للدجاج ما بتسوى بس
انه طبعا اذا انتم بتعرفوا اي نوع لحمه
ومن وين انا لالي يكون هاي بروتين وهاي
خضره ولوكارب اكيد كثير كثير
عم نعمل يوم سلطه مع الكوسا بس الكوسا ما
بتنطبخ الي هو شيء غريب اذا نحن بنقصه
بهذه الطريقه بشكل كتير رقيق نحنا ما
ضروري نطبخ الكوسا بتتقدم علينا الروح
تستعمل بهذا الشكل وبالمان تطلع كثير كثير
رقيقه منير ورحنا عامل الصوص من الحامض
والزيت زيتون اللي هو بيستخدم كثير بالاكل
العربي والاكل من ايطاليا
اليونان وراح نستعمل الافوكادو كمان وكل
انواع الاعشاب مثل النعناع
الزعتر الفراش
[موسيقى]
يعني واضح
اعشاب امور صحيه وهذا هو اللي بميز الاكل
الشرق المتوسط
مزبوط يعني بتلاقي الكوسا كتير هيدا النوع
الاكل مطبوخه او نيء بطريقه تستخدم
طيب احنا يعني لا يمل من مضى للاطباق ولكن
ننتهى الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك لما جمال مؤسسه
مطبخ ومدرسته